[Musique]
non mais
non
amar tou
rocket man nous montrent qu'elles
tournent john dans toute sa splendeur
mais aussi dans toute sa vulnérabilité
le film débute avec des aveux et rothen
est alcoolique boulimique colérique si
dépendant à la cocaïne et au sexe et
comment est ce qu'un petit gros sorti de
nulle part pour devenir une star elton
john a été élevée dans une famille
dysfonctionnelle et rapidement il trouve
refuge dans la musique lui qui a
l'oreille absolue rejeté et humilié par
son père il se sent souvent seul au
monde seraient des faux nez
ça
ce manque d'amour le détruira et le
suivra dissipe le mans toute sa vie dans
ce film il est beaucoup question de
l'homosexualité du chanteur à la croisée
entre comédie musicalité me biographique
rocket man est une vision à la fois et
fantaisiste
la mise en scène est flamboyante avec
ses chorégraphies des plus grands succès
du musicien
[Musique]
l'acteur tony gayton visiblement
renversant possédé par son personnage et
c'est lui qui chante toutes les chansons
avec éclat et audace qu'on pense à
houston à hamster standing en passant
par tiny dancer
et
le film prend de nombreux raccourcis
narratifs mais il n'enlève rien au
plaisir de célébrer l'oeuvre dalton john
et de son parolier bonita open
[Musique]
rocket man par la fiche dès aujourd'hui
et attendez vous à un départ
stratosphérique au box office ici louis
fait depuis mai radio-canada morin